for farmer who belong keeping pests at
bay is part of the job yes I wonder if
we look between the grains for hidden
aphid colonies if there are a foods then
we need to use something against the
buyer of course has an insecticide for
that but at the moment the weed is
healthy and doesn't need to be treated
hundreds might not be the problem but
there are plenty of other pests for this
reason Brown keeps an arsenal of
chemicals at the ready
encounter besides for corn wheat and
later The Hobbit we've got weed killers
for turn up growing quite a bleep about
you have a grain cultivation whom played
in cotati power but then there's also
one for rape seed against weeds and
rapes and crops buyers cropscience
caters for everything they've got agents
against weeds fun G and to stop insect
infestations boobatron uses up to 40
different products quite normal in
conventional farming it's not cheap the
farmer spends as much on pest control as
he does on machinery but he sees no
alternative been getting white sandy if
we didn't treat the wheat with
fungicides and it would get sick the
leaves are dying we'd be left with
shriveled fungus riddled grains no good
for animal fodder let alone human
consumption the crops would only be fit
for the biogas plant yoga Sun log of
life it's simple for the farmer no
spraying of pesticides means no crops
Wolfgang Konstantin keeps his hives a
few kilometers away he's been an avid
beekeeper for 25 years but recently his
colonies have become more vulnerable man
corn flake differ you come to tend the
bees put them out like here and in half
a year there's nothing more inside
sniffs Midland Constantine thinks that
dwindling bee populations could have
something to do with the use of
pesticides
his hives are surrounded by fields five
years ago a defective pesticide was
introduced across the region 10,000 bee
colonies were affected including those
belonging to Vulcan Constantine it was
an accident but ever since then the head
of the Karlsruhe beekeepers association
has become more skeptical over the use
of pesticides the passat either since
Nick Newell the pesticides don't just
poison bees fish that CD there are also
pesticides which are harmful to birds
frogs two partridges Vida and every
person who lives on the land can see it
bhakta dusk you know when there's a
complete and utter travesty shrine I
frommer's like Hoover brown however see
it differently he says pesticides
approved in Germany are harmless and
without the use of such chemicals every
inch of his farm land would be overrun
with weeds with hardly a crop insight he
thinks people are too quick to blame
farmers course is pick you up miss dusty
people need to be better educated about
it but industry doesn't do it they just
want to sell leave you however we have
to talk to passers-by and explain to
them what we're doing how we're doing it
that we're doing it in an
environmentally responsible manner shown
in MA but it seems farmers and
beekeepers have different opinions on
what's environmentally responsible and
what isn't